it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd beauty product nerd and today
we are busting hair care myths
i usually bust beauty myths for free but today's
video is sponsored by pantene even though
it is sponsored everything is my own opinions
and research unfortunately since they're paying
me they expect me to actually do work
we're going to start by looking at the scrape
test i don't know if you remember but back
in the day i did a video debunking this section
from five minute crafts they scraped off some
white stuff on hair with scissors and talked
about how hair products work
it turns out that this test isn't just some
wacky five minute crafts exclusive but it's
actually used by hairdressers and people selling
hair care products to convince you that silicone
is building up on your hair so i thought i'd
do a little experiment
i took two samples of hair i washed both of
these with clarifying shampoo that's meant
to remove buildup and i did this twice to
really make sure i clarified the hair then
i put pantene conditioner on this one only
usually when people do this scrape test they
talk about conditioner with silicones or just
drugstore conditioners with silicones causing
so called buildup there's usually a few myths
around cheap drugstore versus expensive professional
products involved i blow dried both hair samples
to about 90% dryness then i let them air dry
i'm going to scrape them
here's the pantene one with silicones lots
of white stuff coming off so if it's silicone
buildup we shouldn't see it with the hair
that doesn't have conditioner here's the hair
sample without conditioner but we still get
the white buildup coming off if we look through
my little handheld microscope we can see what
looks like microscopic grated parmesan cheese
curls i guess this is a forbidden snack but
you could totally eat hair and on both of
these samples we can see these long clear
curly pieces
so it doesn't look like this white stuff is
built up from conditioner otherwise we'd firstly
see no white stuff coming off the clarified
hair sample with no conditioner and we'd see
a big difference in the sorts of residue coming
off the two different samples
but i think these much more high-powered microscope
images that pantene scientists took of the
residue tells us a bit more about what's going
on the structure of hair is like a cylinder
there's a cortex on the inside and cuticle
on the outside and it's actually the inside
cortex that's colored that's where all the
pigment lives and on the outside the cuticle
this is the part that has that roof shingle
structure that you've probably seen in diagrams
this is actually transparent the white waxy
residue it is mostly just the cuticle getting
scraped off you can see the little roof shingles
here so this scraping test isn't a really
good way to check for residue and if you look
at the microscopic images of the hair afterwards
this is what it looks like it looks like a
split end this test is actually giving you
split ends this scrape test is actually super
damaging so don't do this at home with your
own hair and please don't let someone who
you're paying to make your hair look nice
do this to your hair either so scraping hair
with scissors doesn't show you whether or
not products are building up on your hair
now premium salon hair care products versus
drugstore products specifically conditioners
there's a myth that drugstore conditioners
leave build up while salon products don't
but the truth is all conditioning products
leave stuff on and in the hair this is fundamental
to how they work hair is dead the only living
part is the part inside your scalp the bulb
so the hair up near your scalp the bit that's
just come out of the bulb this is really nice
and neat and it looks a bit like this under
a microscope but hair grows at about 14 centimeters
per year this is about 5.5 inches that's down
to around here so by the time your hair reaches
here it's built up about a year's worth of
damage that's 365 days of brushing washing
sun exposure drying it with heat straightening
it with heat and that's if you don't blast
it with bleach like i did little bits get
snapped off the outside of the cuticle and
it ends up looking a bit like this so you
can imagine the difference between how these
two sections of hair feel closer to your scalp
it feels smooth the longer it is the rougher
it gets and then when you have these battered
surfaces when they smash against each other
then you get more and more damage
to make something battered feel smooth again
sanding it down and wearing it down even more
isn't a really good approach you have to add
stuff back into the hair to plug up the gaps
and that's exactly what all conditioning treatments
do they fill in gaps not just on the surface
but also deeper down they fill in weaker spots
where chunks have washed off or worn away
and all of this extra reinforcement makes
hair more like the intact hair that was newer
it makes it smoother and stronger
if you look at the ingredients list of any
hair conditioner out there well almost everyone
i'm sure there's one out there that breaks
this rule there is going to be a cationic
surfactant these have names like cetrimonium
chloride behentrimonium chloride distearyldimonium
chloride stearamidopropyl dimethylamine and
in the acidic pH of a conditioner all of these
have a positive charge and that positive charge
is really important because that's how they
work when hair is wet it gets negatively charged
opposite charges attract and so these positively
charged bits of the cationic surfactant stick
to your negatively charged hair the scientific
term for this is adsorption and the rest of
the surfactant molecule is oily and so your
hair is now lubricated it smooths it out it
reduces static these cationic surfactants
are the default active ingredients in conditioning
products there are lots of other conditioning
ingredients too polyquaternium polymers hydrolyzed
proteins oils and silicones and it doesn't
matter if they're in high-end luxury conditioners
or if they're in those two-in-one shampoo
and conditioner products that people with
shorter hair tend to use all of these work
by sticking to hair so some amount of buildup
is good and necessary for any conditioner
to actually work but the amount of build up
is really tiny these gaps in your hair are
microscopic you're not going to see these
in a scrape test
so that brings us to the idea that a product
is bad because it weighs down your hair now
what exactly determines how much of a conditioning
ingredient sticks to and stays on your hair
well it depends on a number of factors what
the ingredient actually is how you use the
product on your hair how much is in the product
what the overall formula is how you use the
product on your hair and what your hair is
actually like and i think this is really why
there's this perception that silicones can
build up on your hair and weigh it down if
you use the product that's suited for someone
else's hair on your hair so if you use a product
that's meant for coarse resistant hair on
fine porous hair then it can build up in your
hair and weigh it down and make it greasy
and lank and stick to dust
this actually happened to me right after the
first time i bleached my hair before bleaching
my hair was stereotypical asian hair it was
straight black not very porous so i used an
intensive repair conditioner that had lots
and lots of dimethicone in it and that worked
fantastically but after i bleached my hair
the same conditioner made my hair really limp
and greasy so it wasn't because my old conditioner
was cheap and bad it wasn't my sister still
uses it i have lots of friends who still use
it and love it it just became the wrong product
for my hair type
it's a lot like skin care products and skin
type if you're using products that were made
for dry skin on oily skin you're probably
not going to have a good time and it isn't
like my hair just hates all silicones that's
another misconception silicones aren't all
the same there's a massive variety i found
that my hair loves products with different
silicones like amodimethicone and bisaminopropyl
dimethicone these are silicones that have
a positive charge so they tend to deposit
less on hair positive charges repel each other
so once there's enough silicone stuck to your
hair then extra stuff doesn't stick on as
much and so the chance of your hair getting
overloaded with silicones is a lot lower
on top of this the same name on an ingredient
list could mean different substances going
back to dimethicone dimethicone is a silicone
polymer that has oxygen and silicon atoms
stuck together like this but the polymer can
have different lengths and still be called
dimethicone and these different lengths will
have different properties if it's longer then
the dimethicone will feel a bit thicker and
heavier if it's shorter length then it can
feel more lightweight and spread through hair
a lot more easily if you look at all the different
ingredients that are called dimethicone that
you can buy you'll see that there are lots
of different grades and when i say grades
i'm not talking about higher and lower quality
i'm just talking about different dimethicones
with different properties that are good for
different uses
so sometimes looking at the ingredients list
doesn't help as much as we'd like it to when
we're looking for a conditioner that suits
our hair you need to look at what sort of
hair the conditioner says it's for look at
reviews from other people with similar hair
to you and try it on your own hair
so the moral of the story is there are loads
of different silicones hundreds and thousands
of them they can be incorporated into hair
care products in lots of different ways just
because you've had a bad experience with one
conditioner with silicones doesn't mean you
need to give up on all silicones entirely
and if you do you might be missing out on
some really great products that will work
really well on your hair
i hope this video helped you understand a
bit more about what might be going on with
your hair care products like subscribe nerdification
bell follow me on instagram check out my blog
and i will see you next time for i don't know
if it'll be sunscreen but it will definitely
be nerdy